e é preciso muita força pois é está
perfeito pode pessoal aqui quem fala
artistas muito bem vindos a mais um
vídeo eu hoje trago-vos aqui os dez é só
tem filhos para fazer sushi mas eu
escolhi os 10 mais idiotas aqueles que
eu acho que não vão resultar ok que eu
vou ser sincero aqui neste vídeo ok eu
vou utilizar isso vamos ver o que é que
vai usar o que é que não vai resultar e
se for muito podre eu aí vou admitir que
eu gastei dinheiro para ter que ter rolo
sushi do vidro do veículo os
o que são líquidos shinnazuki já temos
aqui os produtos todos pessoal só papai
agora vou seu like aqui nesse vídeo ok
deixa lá que fizeram mas se não for
inscrito se inscrevam também e bora lá
começar já tenho aqui algumas coisas
preparadas allows the silence falava
aparece mundo soph olha só carne para
sua assim e pronto para fazer os nossos
aqui ó
e eu acho que já estraguei vamos
utilizar as técnicas do da vinci enorme
ventura de peso não deve ser assim sim
depois leva a massa bilhetinho hall aqui
eu acho que fica mais ou menos assim ok
nós temos aqui folha de alguém eu vou
tentar cortar este aqui bem a medida ok
eu não vou tentar fazer isso perfeito
porque supostamente essa máquina tem que
ajudar um principiante uma pessoa que
não percebe nada de sujar o rei ela tem
que me ajudar ok já tenho aqui o arroz
para sushi tem que ser uma ro
específicos não não vai ficar bem
quiserem receita tá embaixo e vou deixar
na descrição até porque eu sou muito
cozinheiro cozinhar tudo eu vou fazer
aqui com salmão ao mesmo um dos
utensílios para equipar este vídeo é
esta colher que eu acho que serve para
tirar o arroz daqui de dentes para a
roxa e fazer tem máquina erguer não sai
já vou falar aqui dentro assim eu não
sei se conseguem ver
se espalhar assim vem o arroz mas eu vou
deixar um espaço no meio porque eu quero
colocar o salmão ali dentro como é que
eu corto diz que eu não sei tá vamos
colocar um salmão aqui vem no meio e no
centro eu vou meter aqui só mais um
pouquinho só para dar aquela que ela
aqui um cara não salvar os que assim a
todos os dias bora lá buscar pessoal
agora é agora ó está mais ou menos assim
é só puxar assim
e eu acho que tá fazer
o ok acho que tá pronta e agora como é
que a gente sai daqui é isso mas tão
perto eu vou ler as instruções calma
entendeu é como eu tô fazendo não é a
outra tá ao contrário ok pessoal ok aqui
o nosso perfeito essa faca é horrível
essa faca é horrível
se não fosse a parte vai explicar
perfeito porque não fica com muito bom
aspeto até passou no teste passou
realmente ficou um rolo incrível eu não
precisei de me expressar muito primeiro
utensílio foi esta máquina o segundo foi
colher eu tenho aqui um terceiro que eu
recebi deu isso e olha aí o
o que é que fiz dois fazem chinês
comenta embaixo que é que sabe usar
pauzinhos um momento estes aqui são
incríveis porque a parte de dentro é de
madeira tens um relevo da para agarrar
muito bem e a parte fora é de metal
portanto eu acho que dá para gastar as
peças bem também só precisa de levar a
boneca ele pode ter aqui o carro lá ó
e aí
e ai eu fui aprovado essa maquininha
função vai lá pessoal quarta utensílio
estúpido para fazer sushi vem dentro
desta caixa os moldes para fazer
niguiris eu não sei se vocês sabem o que
é um idioma dormir é isso que eu vou
tentar fazer um ficar filme basta ok
colocar assim o arroz com muita calma
e não são paulo não estás botar o pé a
e aqui temos o nosso seguir os melhor
aqui soja hahaha ha
o perfect tempo eu tô curioso sofri
muito curioso este princípio é para
fazer dogma de alguma sushi não faz
ideia do que isso é mas é alguma coisa
com couve e carne que eu não consigo
arranjar a curva então tem alface que
nós vamos tentar economizar eu quero um
e eu acho que é só colocar aqui dentro
assim não é faz parte tudo nem sei se
vai funcionar agora a intenção é colocar
uma pasta de carne ali dentro eu comprei
um pa ter tem um aspecto né gente olha
aí um patê de carne de boa qualquer
coisa sei lá eu tive preguiça em fazer
carne a sério então vai assim mesmo
assim eita tá então gente né eu sei eu
tô aqui a ver uai você se insere também
na [ __ ] posta mente é só puxar aqui ela
vem que isso vai fazer toda automática
que acham
e aí
e aqui ó
o homem-aranha de se não deu certo é
e vamos dar o benefício da dúvida para
este porque eu não fiz fosse
ingredientes termos o próximo utensílio
é muito simples pessoal eu tenho aqui
dois pauzinhos para comer sushi e mais
uma coisa muito especial é que vem aqui
com este boneco de borracha quem é que
nunca foi aquele restaurante chinês ou
japonês quando eles dão aquilo que eles
fazem os com elástico isso ajuda as
crianças claramente e ajuda também
pessoa que não sabe comer ainda com
pauzinhos então acho que ela tem sido
muito prático e vocês podem usar em
qualquer pãozinho em qualquer a boca mas
só que não pode ser que a mão assinado
e o que é que esse bocado que você faz
esse aqui deve ser para fazer o bolinho
de arroz eu nunca comi essa peça de
sushi em nenhum restaurante japonês mas
é muito visto em animes e desenhos a
cliente e tal é só colocar um arroz aqui
dentro
e aí
e agora vou soldar aqui uma apressadinha
sim
e aqui uma peça incrível será sair tá se
ok vou colocar áudio aqui por dentro
assim meu digam lá se não ficou incrível
olha isso tá incrível e
g1
e bora lá próximo utensílio nigiri
leitor este é para fazer um ninguém mais
uma forma mais pequena ok este mal daqui
fica assim tipo um quadradão grande né
um retângulo
e a feito
é só que ninguém lhe perfeito agora só
falta o salmão vou ligar peixaria já fez
é só perfeito agora vamos fazer aqui uma
batalha ok eu quero uma batalha nos
comentários quem adora sushi comenta aí
sushi que adora frango assado ou seja
que não gosta de sushi comente frango
assado próximo utensílio aqui está com
verdadeiro que é mack maker é todo meu
eu adoro temaki é uma das principais
peças que eu como sempre o restaurante
japonês é o tema aqui
e agora colocar o arroz espalhar bem ó
esperar bem assim o arroz o salmão
tecnicamente fica gostinho você já
colocado depois mas eu vou já adicionar
um pouquinho fica já aqui mesmo tá sim
ok agora faz mais difícil a partir disso
vai ter que ficar um cone de vocês sabem
quem já que não tem máquina um bom
temaki tem sempre aquela aquela forma
especial que essa coisa de plástico vai
me ajudar a fazer a forma eu não sei
como aquela vontade eu não sei se tem
que apertar assim bem que não estou a
fazer
é mas eu acho que funcionou olha que
belo que marque só fico aqui um
pouquinho aqui porque eu devia ter
colocado mais a mesma está perfeito para
exagerar um pouquinho tá ser um
pouquinho feio meu mas tivesse com cada
lado aqui debaixo aplicável a
é incrível só com esse vídeo já jantei
vai se manca bando cá já muitos fizeram
vídeo com isso eu não vi nenhum até
agora eu acho que ao menos eu não me
lembro porque ele vamos tentar se entrar
aqui o código ela já sei já sei já sei
já sei arroz arroz salmão salmão fechar
empurrar tá uma bazuca cortar acabou
acho que só isso vamos colocar então
arroz aquilo que me faz muita confusão
são as medidas porque eu não sei se deve
colocar tudo cheio ou deixar espaços mas
olha eu vou encher mesmo porque eu adoro
arroz
se tu quiser de arroz com salmão
e é sim
eu vou ter puxar com muito cuidado agora
três vezes um isso elenco bem tranquilo
bem ok agora é só pressionar ok ok ok tu
piscina arroz aqui tá e eu estou aqui no
salão ok eu acho que já está vamos ver o
que é que vai sair daqui
e é preciso muita força tá perfeito tá
perfeito essa o resultado final só fica
um rolo surgir ok agora faço por áudio
por fora ou então não eu vou fazer
alguns furos ó eu vou deixar assim tarde
com alga
e olha isso a perfeito esta faca só não
corta bem é só isso o problema
o problema da faca mas essa bazuca faz o
que promete oque ela faz aqui um corpo
perfeito e não gostar o vídeo para ti
pessoal espero que vocês tenham gostado
que quiser mais um vídeo experimentar o
tecidos de cozinha inclusive já fiz um
vídeo tá embaixo também ajustar
ofensivos para fruta meu tá incrível
passei lá e se quiserem mais comentem
deixe lá e peguei um barreto e até a
próxima tchau